Here the answers were negative 3 plus or minus 5i, imaginary solutions. We
start by simply completing the square, we have our x squared term here and our
x term here. The b value is positive 6, so we find b over 2 which is 3 and then
square this which is 9. We add 9 to both sides of our equation, so that way we
can complete the square on this side. We rewrite our trinominal as the quantity
x plus 3 squared, and then add these two together to get negative 25. We use
our square root method to take the square root of both sides. So x plus 3 can
equal positive or negative 5i. Keep in mind we have a negative radicant here,
so the square root of 25 is 5 and the square root of negative 1 is i. And,
finally, to solve for x, we simply subtract 3 from both sides to get our final
answers.